our next act here is just
a one-of-a-kind wonderful man he is so
gifted
and he's so all about our lord and
savior
let me have a volunteer let me have a
volunteer for tonight where are we at
okay i like martial arts i like all the
martial arts here why don't you hold
that it's not real don't worry
why don't you hold on too all right and
you once you put it in my back
how do you know this is not a good place
to be
so he slaps it and transfers and grabs
how he does that interesting
yeah so here it looks
red you put this gun to my back and d
put this gun in my face wait you
want me to try to kill you
don't hold him yet
[Music]
like this right the cabin to turn
inwards yeah
like that right yeah all right to make
it all come together
there's a little belt address right
before it does the distraction yeah
it's cool i'm just adjusting my
no wait that's not how we did it
okay so uh the biggest changes to the
script originally we had it written that
the boxing glove would hit the girl in
the face i think it'll actually be
easier
and more consistent with the full length
of the story that actually breaks out a
window uh when he pulls out the rocket
instead of the rocket firing at a
building
we get the man of steel syndrome this
guy doesn't kill anyone but he's causing
untold amount of damage
it'd actually be easier if the rocket
flies out and hits a statue of darkwing
duck
you said you'd have a statue model no we
can get one this is a lot for a day
i think we can do it i think we can do
it so ryan you got the gun in my back
pick him up i'm in a bad situation
though if you both pulled the trigger
you shoot each other yeah
you really don't ever be in the position
boom
then questions after he like slaps the
gun out
he like puts it into his right hand like
very quickly somehow
i think he goes oh just my belt
oops not [ __ ] up
yep
[Music]
almost
this time if i if i'm too slow shoot me
these are heavy scenes
and not in the sense that they're long
but in the sense that you're conveying a
ton
in each one you have i think too much
car driving
be trouble for you car's all moving to
get shots inside the car shots outside
the car gets one deck chasing them down
gizmoduck grabbing the car you're doing
car stunts
so you focus on maybe doing one moment
and then being done with it that's my
big red flag is that all a car
driving stuff you're not going to be
able to shoot the other two scenes
and do that all in the same day i just
want to get
one solid shot of of gizmo like
chasing down a car it'll be cooler if
the car is winning don't get me wrong
but from a
feasibility point of view some of the
other videos we've done recently all
those videos have done great
they were all shot in a day it wasn't
really about
the spectacle of it as much as it was
about character moments
what you're really looking for are these
moments with gizmoduck as a character
yeah and those are in there and those
are the easiest parts of the thing so
let's focus on those
and make the production easy
we have to wait until like you
threatened
okay okay all right guys
please don't shoot me listen i'll give
you my wall i'll just give you my wand
i was like i'm gonna shoot you as soon
as you touch my gun you almost ripped
out of my hands [ __ ] fire
so it kind of works it kind of works a
little alright let's try it out let's
try to get it
we'll trade it up after this
[Music]
i'm going to try i'm going to be the
mugger okay you want to okay punching
the woman in the face
is funnier you just said slapstick the
boxing glove breaking the window
i just it's no it's not character on
character interaction
it's not messing up it sounds awful to
say yes
i hate feeding women but it's really
funny no
um it established what was going on with
the gizmoduck right off the bat i think
here's the thing
even if you know nothing about these
characters like if you know nothing
about gizmoduck
amy breaks a window that doesn't it's
like boom okay he just missed
like versus he pops the wrong person in
the face of this boxing glove
then it makes sense so yeah like i mean
i get that that's why i had it written
in the first place
but i don't know i like i think i think
you should keep it character based
here's my this is obviously my only
other critique the darkwing duck statue
hey hey
oh
[Music]
because you can blow up the dark winged
duck statue but the biggest thing you
want here
is you want gizmoduck to be embarrassed
right he's your main character so you
want you want him to constantly be doing
things at the beginning that are
fuck-ups of a level that make him feel
bad
so right now with what we've just talked
about you've got a great setup
it's totally shootable and you've got a
great middle middle character moment
so let's just figure out this ending
okay cool with all that cool looks like
ren's got a
v6 right
[Music]
many things come to mind when you think
of a david fincher film fincher's true
trademark
is deception and it's accomplished
primarily through the use of cgi
and digital compositing it's about how
you use that technology to communicate
your vision
and tell the best story you can